генеральний прокурор та віктор шокін
самої вина думку багатьох експорті встав
причину юрасову кузова країні
політичного щура
на кшталт бас корупцію з його місце сумки
між олігархами цілих та прикриттям
експорт вид-во jute на президента Петра
порошенко ти сну темарі канське це
європейські політики ми його жатимемо шоці
на вигляд за ним за галимова не
антикорупційних реформ і вид
за 3 мкр безвізового режиму з олією та
політтехнолог від 1 обрізавши
відповідно порошенка та грузинські
реформатори Михайло Саакашвілі чи то Давид
сакварелідзе такі мої вуса шанси стати
новим їх ним прокурором дозріла до
відставки широке і очевидно малює
світло і на бліду шокін таким чином ви
зважилися якось виду а ти вбив шпилька
дні три секунди тому що треба щоб
наступати і калугіна розраховував на
кабана і проводьте не доб і ти про які
групи ахметова вилкова коробочка
новинського будуть ще більше не побут
обіймає прокурора гора набір відпустки
руб у тему в Україні china завершив та
7 самі вибори тих заберіть лоба катюх в
цих місцях і здійсниться другий тур
полігоні за садом мером проте шоці
наймає години чекають а їх завершення до
слідаку has проба з барахти свої
прокурорське крісло за рахунок за три
мене карбону
граючи на корінь нашого лідера партію
club бориса філатова
вино ти на великому претенденті на
ямальський хрест у дніпропетровську
ананіч не скандалу може як висовуйся
кубар вибір не боротьбі для формування
образу карбону та філатова як патріоті
вікі худий вузька влада призначають експерти
axe протесту партії кропова і куди
криву фтор вказані при фініці з
дніпропетровщини для
ось що коли почалася війна геннадій
корбан
голи розгойдалася, а вина геннадій корбан
розуму з філатовим то йогу команду і
їжі ніхто про ти стоячи у сепаратистам
закони у російського сну там другим
дніпропетровську чи місто від сепаратизму
і утримали дні за заслугами експорту
віктора зам'ятина за ручну камуса ту
асистів президент порошенко
йому за розстріл показати ефективність
боротьби з корупцією
тореза все для заходу мечу йому про ти
сьогодні ми чуємо а
і бачимо заяву про цінники в європейській
комісії очеретів
ентих європейська структур проти
україни держав просто ніг із отриманих
статтю тобто ще вкрадені архіву
пачино ти факти на боротьбу з корупцією та
притягла миру на прокуратуру в Україні
армійці будні все повної батоги і більше
масштабним протестам президенту давай так
і ланцюги два з чого ти ставка югре
відкриває з правої проти зростання поза
ким та нижчих олігархічних груп
віддаюся і ми фірташ і левочкін а то хм
цього